[Musique]
regarde ça, tu vois qu'ils gagnent de l'
argent grâce au jeune homme, oh mon Dieu,
un de ces gens m'a en fait dit
qu'ils avaient gagné des milliers de dollars grâce à moi.
J'étais comme bien
[Musique]
né au Texas et je n'arrêtais pas de m'arrêter au Nouveau-Mexique.
Orléans parce que c'était le seul endroit
où je pouvais encore être, vous savez,
ouvert d'esprit, amusant et énergique face à la
vie, mais je n'étais pas obligé de m'arrêter à deux
heures du matin ou de rester
au bar avec mon verre ou tout le reste.  des choses
qui sont un peu typiques de la
culture américaine, nous sommes ici, c'est la
pluie de ce matin que vous voyez ici, c'est
le truc à la Nouvelle-Orléans, vous
savez, l'eau a tendance à traîner un
peu tandis que dans chaque tronc de la Nouvelle-
Orléans, vous pouvez trouver des hauts.
[Applaudissements]
si vous n'êtes pas pour moi, je vous souhaite à
tous la bienvenue dans ma merveilleuse
[Musique] [
Musique]
jouez-vous toujours ensemble ouais, donnez-
lui un chèque maintenant,
merci
[Musique]
aussi, c'est pourquoi j'avais l'habitude de le faire  jouer avec un
tube de gros monsieur
James et tout le monde étant un enfant de quatre ou cinq
ans
frère de deux jours le samedi dimanche nous avons
gagné environ quatre cents dollars de paix
et de gémissements Wow chaque week-end il y a une
belle chose c'est une belle chose
dont nous l'avons vu venir  tu
sais, d'un enfant qui jouait dans les rues et qui
jouait ici, c'est notre scène
ici,
c'est pour ça que j'ai appris la plupart de mes premières
musiques, tu n'as pas fait un peu de claquettes
[Musique]
il mélange le truc du groupe de branche avec du
rock avec du funk avec  le jazz c'est cool Ivan
et sa famille sont ceux qui ont mis
le funk dans ma vie ouais, sa famille a
aidé à créer le son que nous connaissons sous le nom de
Nouvelle-Orléans et pour qu'il en fasse partie,
j'ai la chance de pouvoir être
autour d'une famille et Ivan juste à côté
de lui le regardant jouer, je suis capable de
m'imprégner de quelque chose et de le mettre avec
mon groupe et différentes choses à la Nouvelle-Orléans
absolument et c'est un peu vrai, comme dans
certains quartiers, on engendre plus
certains types de  petites variations sur
le truc de la Nouvelle-Orléans comme si vous aviez beaucoup
de batteurs ouais qui venaient probablement d'en
haut, vous savez que vous n'avez pas de cornistes
de la 6ème guerre de la région de Treme,
vous savez, vous savez, beaucoup de chats
jouaient de la guitare de la Civil  La guerre
ouais, vraiment comme ça et puis il y a
des cancers qui jouent tout ce qu'ils
essaient de jouer partout mais c'est en quelque sorte
un mélange et un match vous savez
et donc nous apprenons tous les uns des autres
[Musique]
J'avais l'habitude d'y aller  église juste là
en ce moment nous sommes encore intermédiaires donc j'ai
été baptisé dans cette église je
vivais dans cette maison
13:15 et puis plus tard nous avons vécu dans cette
maison vous avez déjà entendu parler d'un James Black,
ils vivaient dans la maison d'à côté  portez
le drame James Black ouais, c'est une
chose à propos des portefeuilles et à chaque pâté de maisons, il
y a un individu célèbre que vous connaissez,
quelqu'un qui a déjà été influencé ou d'
une manière ou d'une autre ou juste le
groupe du quartier, vous savez, la musique a
toujours été, vous savez, la force motrice de
la culture des portefeuilles que vous connaissez et
sera toujours
[Musique]
donc c'est la maison donc nous avions l'habitude de
répéter dans cette arrière-salle ici ouais,
vous pouvez probablement monter les marches
et le voir ouais, nous avions l'habitude de répéter
juste ici, je veux dire  nous jouons
ensemble maintenant, en fait, j'avais 36
ans, je jouais ensemble 30 douzaines
[Musique]
des douzaines, c'est génial, nous écoutons leurs
disques encore et encore et encore
quand nous avons commencé la rivière
[Musique]
n'a pas un fort  influence sur moi
et la renaissance dès le début, vers
1982, j'enseignais à l'école,
j'enseignais à Carmen et beaucoup d'
autres gars qui participaient à la renaissance,
c'étaient des petits enfants, vous savez, ils ont eu la
renaissance ensemble et leur permettraient vraiment
pour mûrir, ils ont commencé à résoudre
pour nous à la Glass House, nous allions à
la Glass House dans le centre-ville et regardions les
Dirty Dozen jouer tous les lundis soir, hé
mon président, cinq ou six ans ou
quelque chose comme ça, nous avons commencé à voyager et puis
au point où les outils ont commencé
de plus en plus longtemps, nous ne pouvions pas
revenir le lundi, alors ils ont embauché la
renaissance pour nous remplacer, c'est la
tradition de la Nouvelle-Orléans, un mauvais après-midi,
vous savez, jusqu'au bout, ouais, nous sommes
tous entrelacés, vous savez, c'est comme un véritable
réseau de musiciens.  et tout comme ça,
il était juste un grand joueur avec nous, il
ne pouvait même pas atteindre maintenant, c'est son heure
hé, qu'est-ce que tu fais ici, vas-y
[Musique] [
Musique] la
musique rebondissante, c'est vraiment ce que ça fait,
comme
des corps qui rebondissent de haut en bas  encore et
encore et c'est oui,
c'est l'énergie des DJ qui ont créé
le rebond en 1987, Mannie Fresh DJ ERV, ces
gars-là l'ont fait pour les danseurs, pas
beaucoup de gens qui s'assoient et
écoutent simplement de la musique rebondissante dès qu'elle
arrive sur tout le monde  tu sais, ils sautent
et les filles s'emparent des choses et
ça arrive très vite comme ça, la musique la plus
populaire de la ville maintenant
[Musique]
et je mettrai les clics pour les chansons, je
ne veux pas utiliser mon clic oh tu dois
l'avoir  du nouvel équipement, je vois Gus qui a envie de
poulet dedans, de
sauce piquante, de crevettes, de
saucisses fumées, de la viande en ragoût quelque part là-
dedans, ça n'a pas l'air bien 10 minutes
non, je n'ai pas 10 ans, environ 500 autres, mets-
le là avec
[Musique]
[  Musique]
très bien
tu étais incroyable à Lafayette oh c'était
merveilleux ça - un de mes
moments forts mon dieu ouais merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup tu es fabuleux
c'est le seul magasin de musique que nous avons
et  je vends de vrais CD, il y a l'un des seuls
endroits où il nous reste
peut-être qu'il y a de la crème,
nous vendons la plupart de nos nouveautés, toute cette musique
et vous pouvez trouver de la musique ici que vous
ne trouverez pas sur Internet, vous ne
la trouverez dans
aucun autre magasin.
compte avec le public
[Musique]
tout le monde veut me rabaisser
[Musique] [
Musique]
yo vraiment Trombone Shorty Je suis désolé, vous avez tous
vraiment des problèmes,
j'ai connu sa mère avant sa naissance, ce
qui signifie que maman et son père étaient de bons amis avec
sa mère  et papa salut mon Rebirth Brass Band
lors de notre premier défilé de deuxième ligne peut-être 15
ans avant la naissance de Trombone Shorty,
puis j'ai vu sa mère, je sors [
Musique]
déplace des trucs dans ma camionnette merdique si
tu me vois faire quelque chose de mal, nous ne le faisons pas  il n'y
a pas beaucoup de lois ici quand il s'agit de
conduire librement, de faire ce que vous voulez, de
rester frais. La Nouvelle-Orléans, c'est avant tout
le bar de quartier, le bar où
je joue tous les samedis est à deux pâtés de maisons
de cette façon.  rue, vous pouvez
voir que cette rue a de très jolis
arbres au milieu
et tout ce qu'ils essaient de déplacer,
ils essaient de fermer tous les bars
ici pour pouvoir en faire une
belle avenue.  que les gens
blancs voudront vivre, tu
sais qu'en ce moment, c'est assez violent et un
peu fou dans la mesure où tu connais cette zone
ici, nous essayons de la garder en dehors
du ring
- bref pour vous - nous y allons, je veux acheter
la musique que tu as nouvelle, je ne la vois pas, c'est
maintenant, je vais me brancher, je
m'appelle Jesse James, je fais partie du
numéro 5 de ta famille, tu es dans le
feu noir ici, probablement l'un des seuls
labels encore tachés après
Katrina  ils vendent des chaussures ils vendent de la musique
il y a un bon endroit pour acheter des CD rebonds un
bon succès des CD hip-hop locaux Rhapsody
toutes sortes de voies commerciales pour équilibrer
le R&B et voici Chris Young et il
gère différents artistes et plusieurs
artistes, c'est si difficile d'obtenir ça
répétition d'être le meilleur rappeur en
nous parce qu'il y en a trop, la
Nouvelle-Orléans se réalise et un rappeur est
tellement de pur talent et une grande partie
passera inaperçue parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à mettre en place
leur structure du point de vue commercial,
certaines personnes  Je ne veux rien avoir
à voir avec l'industrie
et il se trouve qu'ils font partie des
personnes qui sont assises sur des rapports faisant état d'une
quantité incroyable de talents, mais cela essaie de
les convaincre que vous savez qu'il
est important de s'impliquer dans votre carrière.  et
prendre tout cela en faisant un travail très dur
pour que cela se produise à la Nouvelle-Orléans,
cela ne fonctionne pas vraiment comme ça, comme si le
talent seul suffisait à certaines personnes, il suffit d'
avoir le talent et il est difficile d'
aimer naviguer qui veut qui veut
travailler ça  dur, vous connaissez quelqu'un comme
Lil Wayne, vous savez, il y a une raison pour laquelle
il compose cent cinquante nouvelles chansons par
an parce qu'il n'arrête jamais de travailler.
Les gens de la Nouvelle-Orléans sont peut-être
assez talentueux pour faire ça, mais
ils ne veulent pas tous travailler aussi dur et
essayer de savoir qui peut, c'est la
partie la plus difficile de
l'argent sur le bois pendant que tu es fou si
tes garçons ne soufflent pas pendant que tu es occupé J'ai
un nouveau disque que je ne savais pas pour le moment
il est exclusif, personne n'a jamais entendu
[Musique  ]
parce que cet enregistrement hier soir mais comme
dans ma
[Musique]
parfois je trouve le refrain
parfois il trouve un refrain tu
sais je ne sais juste pas les couplets et tout
ce que nous faisons en laissant la musique du feu
c'est pour ça que j'ai été nommé ce n'est rien  pourquoi
tout voulait être viré dans le
sens où tu sais bien, comme tu sais que le
feu est si bon, il a fait une grande partie du
travail préparatoire, ne te méprends pas parce que
tu sais que je l'appelle le plug man, c'est
comme si tu savais
[Musique]
ça  c'était vraiment magique de pouvoir être
dans ce quartier c'est là que
tout a commencé ici cette maison Kermit
Ruffins vivait par là mon frère ma
famille Rebirth Brass Band vivait
au coin de la rue Santa Ana c'est
pourquoi ils ont commencé au coin
il y a un  quartier musical c'est comme
ça que tout le monde est musicien ici
et tous les musiciens mon cousin Terrence
Andrews il vivait là-bas avec la
fanfare des petits coquins donc c'était
toujours de la musique autour voir même les gros de tuba
il est toujours là avec nous donc il voulait un
gros de tuba
[Musique  ]
hé M.  jereth, comment vas-tu,
je vais bien ouais, je t'aime aussi, merci
mr.  jereth j'ai apprécié
[Musique]
de voir que tous les mercredis soirs nous avons eu
la garniture d'une fanfare qu'ils jouent ici
et c'est oncle Benny sur une caisse claire
et nous venons de perdre nous venons de perdre un
grand-oncle I&L avec la garniture d'une
fanfare à la basse  tambour nous venons de le perdre
merci chose préférée c'est le
seul endroit où nous venons tous les mercredis c'est
vrai
nous avions l'habitude de nous installer ici avec le
barbecue nourrir tout le
quartier et de la musique gratuite toute la nuit
ici nous avions tous l'habitude de jouer juste de la musique
oh vraiment
ouais comme un âne tu vas bien
tu as l'air bien tout ce
quartier va exploser jusqu'à 300
personnes dans la rue c'est fou comme une
scène de film les musiciens Shannon Powell
Kermit Ruffins Reaper frère tout
et maintenant tu le regardes et c'est vide
il y a  rien ce gars il dort dans
le cimetière c'est là qu'il habite dans
la rue au centre il dort sur
la grille eh bien Katrina la grosse tempête que nous
avons eu en 2005 et en août et tout le monde nous
étions tellement habitués à vivre d'une certaine façon et
tout était tout simplement  c'était bien pour nous et
un jour, la tempête avait
tout effacé et quand nous sommes revenus en
ville, vous avez eu beaucoup de prix abusifs et
certaines des personnes qui étaient ici
vivaient dans des maisons différentes et
tout ce que j'avais les moyens de me permettre
ils ne pouvaient tout simplement pas le faire, cela n'est pas
revenu naturellement, il y a des
histoires de gens comme cette
fille, Ephraim, mais j'ai complètement oublié, tu
sais, elle est sortie sur le porche après le
passage de Katrina, le soleil sortait,
tout avait l'air vraiment sympa et puis
tout  tout d'un coup, elle a regardé dans la rue
et elle a vu de l'eau venir, vous savez, au
moment où elle est entrée dans sa maison pour
dire à son mari que l'eau était à la hauteur de
la poche au moment où ils sont tous deux
retournés pour prendre ce qu'ils
pouvaient.  Je n'ai pas pu sortir alors qu'ils
marchaient dans l'eau et en
moins d'une heure, l'eau avait
atteint 25 pieds. Ils étaient en train de
faire un trou dans le
toit pour se sauver, ils ont dû
monter sur le toit de toute façon et  a-t-elle dit, alors
qu'elle était sur le toit le lendemain,
c'est à ce moment-là que les grenouilles, les insectes et tout
cet espace essayant de sortir de l'
eau sont arrivés sur la maison, alors elle a dû
les renverser et tout comme ça
se protéger parce qu'elle était  être
infesté de toutes sortes d'
animaux différents qui ont survécu
ainsi que des insectes, des grenouilles et des trucs comme
ces serpents,
donc c'était mauvais partout ici, le lac
a ajouté
[Musique] [
Musique]
comme vous pouvez le voir chez mon voisin, il était
sous l'eau  il était sous l'eau et il
ne reviendra pas il est à Baton Rouge
il a juste dû nager dans un océan différent
tu sais ce type n'est pas de retour il ne
reviendra pas cette maison a été démolie et
j'étais juste tu sais que sauter de l'eau était là
voir mon voisin ici  il a commencé à
réparer ce qu'il a fait hé Chrissy allez
Chrissy y
va assez J'étais en tournée avec Lenny
Kravitz Je suis rentré à la maison et deux ou trois
jours après être à la maison, nous recevons cet avertissement de grosse tempête
et j'ai quitté la ville
quelques heures  avant qu'ils
n'atterrissent, j'ai dû retourner en tournée donc c'était
une chose bizarre pour moi parce que nous avions
des membres de notre famille que nous ne pouvions pas attraper, oh,
il ne pouvait pas bien aussi et nous ne pouvions pas
le joindre et j'ai dû y aller  de retour en tournée
et finir ce que nous faisions
Oh Katrina, l'eau est montée jusqu'aux dents
en haut de ce toit juste là ouais
donc tout en bas a été anéanti, j'ai
inondé tous les souvenirs que j'avais
collectés du monde entier,
tout ce qui était en bas  anéanti
et après m'a volé la tête Oh un arbre seul
Remorque FEMA ici pendant environ au moins deux
ans Remorque FEMA vous savez que c'était là-bas, c'était
inconfortable mais c'est pour ça que c'était
mes voisins ici, cette maison était une
loi mais ils l'avaient surélevée mais quand
le plus fort est venu l'eau était sur le
toit tu sais quand c'était quand c'était
avant, c'était élevé parce que c'est
la nature de la Nouvelle-Orléans nous aimons Venise
maintenant, tôt ou tard tu sais que nous allons devoir
trouver un moyen de coexister avec le
l'eau, c'est vrai Dexter tu connais chaque maison
parce qu'elle vient, elle viendra ouais tu sais
même après la tempête je n'ai même jamais
envisagé de partir tu sais que je n'ai jamais
voulu aller nulle part je n'ai jamais voulu être
ailleurs j'ai toujours su que tu savais que
je revenais et réparais  et tu
sais, revenir à la maison, tu sais, avant
la tempête, il y avait des gens qui ne
quittaient jamais le neuvième quartier, c'était une grande différence.
Katrina a forcé les gens à sortir et l'a emmené.
Je veux quitter la Nouvelle-Orléans mais c'était
facile pour moi parce que la seule chose qui me
retenait  moi ici après que tous les
parents et proches soient allés
ailleurs, c'était la camionnette et Baton Rouge est
exactement à soixante miles de là, il y a un bus
qui vous emmène aller et venir pour dix
dollars cinq heures dans chaque sens, vous savez qu'il y
avait tellement d'avantages à simplement  reste
là, moins de drames, je n'ai pas besoin de
travailler, mais si j'ai un bateau ou pas, si
quelqu'un a volé mon bateau, je dois
m'inquiéter, tu sais, dormir une nuit
et commencer à flotter pendant que je dors,
tu sais que je peux toujours cuisiner.  la même nourriture
tu sais tu sais ça ici tu
sais pour Louis Armstrong ici il était à
la maison des garçons de Milne
de cette façon il les a appris gratuitement c'était une
maison de garçons ici les garçons
ouais ils s'appellent The Waifs
nous appelons ça 928 sous l'
intestat
c'est  pourquoi tous les gens traînent
oh ouais
en tant que moi quand j'étais enfant
et c'est mon frère en tant que James juste là
[Musique] [
Musique]
ouais tu as même eu un travail
[Musique]
c'est incroyable
as-tu appelé je suis comme la
surveillance du quartier  mec,
nous évitons les ennuis près du bloc M le Milner
et je connais tout le monde, de
l'arbre Ness à cet arbre, c'est ce qui fait une
communauté, tu sais, ok, ne le laisse pas te
mordre les doigts comme tu le
sais, mets les choses en ordre, rien de plus, laisse-
le tomber  si vous le tenez au-dessus de sa tête,
il lèvera la tête, vous saurez
ce
conduit vocal, vos proches le rendront
sur mon argent, prenez une fille de
haute joaillerie sainte et c'est ma fille et
et je suis fou  je
n'ai plus que ce nombre de disques maintenant je me suis
débarrassé de presque tout ce que j'avais
avant de faire quelques
disques vinyles pour les artistes rebondissants ouais, c'est
un Big Freedia un Satori 12 pouces que j'ai
fait avec eux avec un disque punk  label
d'Austin,
je suis un terme d'argot positif pour les enfants gays, ce
qui rend tout cela encore plus
ironique que nous travaillons avec un label punk
et que les enfants gays sont appelés les
rappeurs punks avec qui je travaille ici à la Nouvelle-
Orléans lorsqu'ils jouent dans un noir.  Le club
compte 1 500 personnes et seulement 10 % d'entre eux
sont gays, vous savez, les rappeurs gays ou transgenres
sont les réussites culturelles dominantes
de cette ville, dans leur
propre ville, c'est du jamais vu. Je ne sais pas s'il existe à peu près
quelque chose comme une très bonne musique rebondissante.
sur les mp3 maintenant,
il n'y a pas, il n'y a pas de disques, il n'y a pas de
cassettes, c'est juste que tu vas au
magasin du coin, ils n'ont même pas de magasins de disques,
alors tu vas au magasin du coin et il
y a un gars dans le parking et il
ouvre son coffre et  vous lui achetez des CD
et les artistes eux-mêmes n'en tirent jamais d'
argent et les producteurs de
musique n'en reçoivent jamais
et c'est comme ça que ça marche, les gens
le font juste parce qu'ils l'aiment et
ils continuent
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] c'était
un enfant dans lequel j'ai toujours voulu
pouvoir être comme Galactic et Neville
Brothers et jouer à certaines périodes de
l'année que Ben a probablement rencontré  moi quand j'avais
trois ou quatre ans et je passais
beaucoup de temps avec
la fanfare des petits coquins, il y avait un
groupe de mes cousins ​​et des membres de ma famille
là-bas et Ben et moi jouions
ensemble depuis ma naissance  Je suppose que j'ai
eu de la chance, comment as-tu pu ne pas oublier
[Musique],
c'est un tel honneur pour moi parce que quand
tu peux jouer du House of Blues et
vendre à guichets fermés, c'est aussi un autre niveau que
tu as atteint dans la ville de la Nouvelle-
Orléans.  c'est une bénédiction de pouvoir faire
ça c'est un endroit génial car il
rassemble beaucoup d'artistes nationaux mais nous
faisons la plupart de notre sale boulot à Tipitina's
Tipitina's est un peu en dehors des
sentiers battus c'est dans le
quartier français alors peut-être  cet endroit pourrait attirer
la clientèle pourrait tirer un peu plus
de l'économie touristique alors que
Tipitina est plus une destination ouais
tu ne vas pas simplement passer par Tina,
tu dois y aller
[Musique]
pour galactique, c'est notre club d'origine qui est
vraiment à peu près  le seul endroit où nous jouons,
oui
galactic, tu sais, je dois juste les voir
en live et Ben est toujours très innovant,
tu sais, la musique, le spectacle et la façon dont
les choses se déroulent, c'est juste une de ces
choses incroyables qu'il faut voir en live
et j'en ai encore beaucoup à faire.  eux aussi, je
n'ai tout simplement pas encore l'argent pour faire les lumières
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes des fusions sur une rangée de PT qui est un
tableau d'acceptation dans  La Nouvelle-Orléans ce soir, c'est des
spectacles de dragsters
d'artistes de drag de l'extérieur de la ville.
Je pense que c'est un peu fou ici, il y a
certainement eu beaucoup de violence dans
le passé et vous savez, beaucoup de
bagarres sur les parkings et des trucs comme ça, mais c'est
un moment de calme.  un petit peu et je ne
reste jamais jusqu'à la toute fin, c'est-à-dire avec
tout ce qui nous fait tomber, tu sais, si tu
pars comme juste avant que ce soit fini,
d'habitude, tout va bien, bienvenue à la
fin de ta carrière, maintenant au début de ma
chienne, je suis Nikki Oh Nikki à  être la
[Musique]
Je suis vraiment doué avec certaines règles et
des trucs comme ça comme le mettre en place le mettre en place
dans busty pop it up par busty pop it up
derrière des choses comme s'ils ne s'inventaient pas
si heureux de  je remercie mais ce ne
sont pas nécessairement des mots que vous connaissez, donc j'aime
utiliser une voix comme si c'était juste un
instrument
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous savez, j'ai pardonné aux gens parce que je suppose que j'ai
grandi, j'ai grandi avec un hétérosexuel
encore gras et dégueulasse je reprends le
projet I'm Rose tu en connais un autre
comme moi tu sais donc tu connais ici mon sac
donc c'est comme un quotidien ils me soutiennent tu
sais et si tu joues avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Applaudissements]
comme vraiment très amical si vous
êtes qui vous êtes un grand idiot mais c'est
comme si le Sud était fondamentalement plein de
portes comme si autant dire que
le Sud est la capitale de la gay
parce que nous '  C'est comme partout ici, nous
avons des hypothèques dans les rues, ils le font
maintenant dans la ville mais c'est comme unifier pour
moi les choses comme si tout le
monde pouvait rebondir, la Nouvelle-Orléans
se trouve être vraiment vraiment
comprendre quel butin ils secouent leur
conseil d'administration, ce sont leurs secrétaires, c'est un
penses-tu qu'ils épaulent tu sais si
jamais tu leur donnes l'impression que
tu sais que c'est bien tu sais que c'est comme si
nous avions grandi avec ça comme si c'était tout ce que
tu voyais non tout c'est comme si tu voyais c'est
comme si l'attitude était une question d'attitude c'est
comme si j'étais  comme paralysé comme si cela venait
si naturellement c'est comme si tu savais que tu le fais
si bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
[Rires]
et il est le monde  la plus grande musique
riche du quartier, vous n'aviez pas d'autre
choix que d'apprendre la musique et quand les
gens plus âgés vous encouragent dès votre
plus jeune âge et que vous savez que c'est comme
rendre les gens fiers de vous pour avoir fait
quelque chose que vous voulez faire, alors nous
voulions le faire  être capable de voir si nous pouvons utiliser
ce type de système qu'on nous a enseigné
et c'est à nous de pouvoir aider
les enfants de toute la ville. Dans toute la ville,
beaucoup de gens ne réalisent pas qu'il a fallu
la musique de la Nouvelle-Orléans pour exister.  là-bas,
faites savoir à tout le monde que c'est quelque chose
qui va nous manquer si nous voulons
reconstruire et nous remettre ensemble,
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait disparaître,
c'est pourquoi la musique est si importante
à préserver et vous connaissez cette culture
parce que maintenant nous donnons  revenons à ces
enfants qui vont le transmettre à leurs
enfants, ils le transmettent à leurs amis
et gardent la musique vivante si je sauve la
vie d'une personne grâce à la musique, mon
point fort, j'ai fait mon travail, nous prenons toutes
les nationalités, toutes sortes de
saveurs ou  des sentiments différents et nous
l'avons simplement mis en place et peu importe ce que nous
en trouvons et c'est ça
tout à la Nouvelle-Orléans, je m'en fiche de
ce que c'est, de la musique à l'imbécile en passant par le simple fait de
sortir avec les gars
[Musique]
ça remonte à loin  dès le
début de la ville, c'était une ville portuaire,
donc les navires qui remontaient et descendaient le fleuve
et traversaient l'océan, il y avait toujours un
grand mélange de gens et donc je pense que la
musique est venue avec ce
mélange de gens.
[Musique]
nous jouons comme nous vivons nous jouons comme nous
dansons donc c'est généralement vous frappez comme si vous
pouviez entendre un musicien de la Nouvelle-Orléans partout dans
le monde, où qu'il soit, lorsque vous mettez
ce disque de Louis Armstrong avec cette
trompette, vous pouvez entendre qu'il a
quelque chose là-bas  qu'aucun d'entre nous n'a
jamais été capable d'expliquer qu'il suffit d'
être ici, cela devient un mode de vie,
maintenant notre industrie semble être
la culture, la musique, l'art et la nourriture, ce qui, à mon
avis, est un endroit vraiment agréable pour avoir
des spécialités.
[Musique]